hey 2020 haven't done a book video for
quite a while so I thought that what I
could do is summarize all of these books
here everything that I read in the
Reading Challenge on Goodreads last year
I'm gonna rank every book that I read
from the bond that I enjoyed hate it but
I didn't enjoy it very much
all the way up to my number one read
which was fantastic if you'd like to
keep on top of what I'm reading more
regularly then I recommend following me
on Goodreads they'll be linked down
there in the description to my profile
also in the description is a link to
every book that I talked about to the
Amazon page of those books if you would
like to buy one then you can use those
links that I would encourage you to
support your local book shops especially
if it's an independent book shop frankly
Jeff Bezos doesn't need the money
but if you do choose to buy something
for this Amazon links than I do get a
percentage it's not very much but I get
something so if you wanna support me you
can do that starting off at the bottom
of the pile unfortunately the hidden
life of trees this is a book that I've
heard a great deal about loads of people
recommended it to me I really didn't
like it I should say that the subject
matter of this book is interesting trees
are fascinating to me
I have long loved forests hanging around
near trees it's kind of like a very
calming thing to do for me
but I did not like the way this book was
written it's it comes in these sort of
pithy bite-sized chunks which are
literally like five pages long in some
cases it's like reading a book of tweets
it does hang together but it's like
that's not a chapter I can't take a
discretized reading experience from that
alright it's not enough I found it way
too stop-start II I just interesting
stuff but told in the wrong way for me
next up something that's bit more of
home territory for me lucky planet by
David Wolfram this is a book basically
about the anthropic principle in a
nutshell that's what this book is about
it's about how perhaps we are here able
to comprehend the universe because
actually the earth is really quite
remarkable in the we are very lucky to
live on earth the conditions here are
just right for life we shouldn't think
that there are lots of planets out there
which are habitable and you know the
book makes a good case perhaps I know
too much about the subject anyway I
basically read it
was a present actually so I was probably
going to read it that we brewed not to
and it is interesting I found the author
a little bit too jokingly if I'm
completely honest with you god I've got
a lot of books to get through it we got
to do like really rapid reviews
basically if you find that idea
interesting then you should give this a
read especially if you're interested in
sort of deep history of earth looking
back hundreds of millions and billions
of years it's a good introduction but
again not for me next something
completely different
may we borrow your language by Philip
Gooden this is a book about etymology
and a little bit like the hidden life of
trees it suffers from the same problem
of being very stop starti so it's not
like a narrative of how narrow language
evolves it's about how individual words
have evolved so gawrsh for example go
gawrsh I'm gonna have to edit that out
the chapter is literally that many pages
and then we're on to serendipity and
then were on to kayak sandwich and the
the thread that goes through the book is
the age of the word so the oldest word
in here is wheel wheel yeah that's not a
word in modern English I was having a
stroke for a second then signifies a
Celt basically it's plural form is the
basis of Wales and the Welsh it's from
60 so 690 the eighth century is the
first recognizable word which is thing
I'm a ethnology nerd I really like
etymology and so I picked this up
literally complete impulse by and it is
interesting again it suffers from the
same problem they've been very stop
start II but I found the individual
chapters more interesting this is you
know it's a good book there is the
etymological which my mum has
recommended to me and I think a few
other people in this channel have which
i think is a more of a kind of overview
which of what I'm more interested in
when it comes to etymology like Big
Ideas how words change over time and I
mean this is obviously talking a lot
about how English has borrowed words
from anglo-saxon German French Old
French Latin in
all over the world that stuff's
interesting again I feel like I keep
complaining about the format again the
format just annoys me a little bit with
this book but it's an interesting read
next a book which I don't actually have
because I think I lent it to my mum what
walls could talk by Lucy Worsley this is
billed as a history of the home and it
is but it's specifically a history of
the English home and it looks at the
bathroom the bedroom the living room and
the kitchen and it's an interesting
domestic history it's a little bit of
like frothy history if that's the right
word to use it's a little bit
introductory which you know is the
purpose of the book is not an academic
book at the end of the day I found it a
little bit narrow focused on just the UK
and England really it doesn't even
really go beyond the English borders I
would have enjoyed something that was a
bit more global it was nice and chatty
in its style but I would have preferred
it to be a little bit more in depth I
guess if you're interested in domestic
history though and how we arrived at for
example having a kitchen in the house as
opposed to in a separate you know
building how we arrived at you know
something obvious like a flushing toilet
but also something like toilet paper it
was an interesting read actually I would
recommend it next up and probably
controversially lowdown homo Deus by
Yvonne Noah Harare several of these
books in this list I have reviewed
elsewhere review everything on my
Goodreads that I read but I did a whole
video on this so I refer you to that
basically it's no sapiens but it's
pretty interesting
check out the link in the description
for the video on this one if you want to
learn more my thoughts coming to the
midpoint of the list next up is the
hockey stick and the climate Wars by
Michael Mann this is good this is the
tipping point of the list where I was
stopping stop having so many problems
with the format of the book and I can
look past those books and just really
enjoyed it the hockey stick refers to a
graph in climate science which is
basically showing that earth's
temperature had been relatively stable
for a long time and then anthropogenic
climate change kicks in and it shoots up
at the end like a hockey stick Michael
Mann is one of the key scientists
associated with it he kind of came up
with the original version of it there
have been several since and the book is
partly a
the climate science behind it but it's
also about the attacks made on it and on
Michael Mann since he has become a
lightning rod for chronic climate
skeptics people who deny under pretended
climate change and also as a consequence
people on the right wing establishments
right so in the right wing establishment
in America and the book is partly about
his personal experience and I think that
personal aspect is going to be more
interesting some people than to others I
think I would have preferred a bit more
in the broad overview perhaps something
a bit more like merchants of doubt but
you know if you're interested in the
human side of climate change as well as
the actual science this is an excellent
primer for the actual science and for
the individuals that you know did the
science what is kind of interesting is
that it is written to be legally
watertight like he talks about a
programming trick in when he was a kid
he was learning how to program and he
basically found a shortcut like a little
trick and he had to explain in minut
detail what that meant when he used the
phrase a programming trick because it's
the kind of thing that people would read
you know a trick in the mathematical
analysis when you're looking at
something like a temperature data set
some people would say like wait a minute
I means you're fudging the data so it's
kind of funny that you can see that he
his brain is working to make everything
he says as watertight as possible just
kind of sad really it's necessary but an
interesting personal story right ok I'm
cheating a little bit here I'm lumping a
whole series of books together because I
read 25 books last year and a lot of
them was this series there are God how
many books you even are in the series
there are 15 books in this series which
is called ghosts the first one came out
in the mid 90s and the last one an arc
here at the bottom I know it came out
this year and basically this was kind of
like my young adult Harry Potter is a
series that I have read every book of I
know all the characters by heart
I have reread several of them several
times and in anticipation for the final
book coming out I reread the whole
series so starting oh they're actually
completely out of order
I think with the founding first and only
and then working my way through down to
an arc was a really interesting
experience I reviewed all of them on my
Goodreads oh they're about Warhammer by
the way probably should have said that
sooner basically it's a series set in
the Warhammer 40,000 universe about an
Imperial Guard regiment which is a
series of humans fighting other humans
and occasional aliens xenos sorry and
it's a format that is basically the
Sharpe series but instead of being the
Poli onic combat it is combat in the
41st millennium incredibly dorky I'm not
gonna say that it is stellar writing Dan
Abnett who is the author as a New York
Times bestseller he also co-wrote
guardians of the galaxy and you know
he's gone on to do things way beyond
Warhammer but this is his single largest
opus I think and while it's not Ulysses
it is very fun to read is crunchy the
books basically all suffer from the same
drawbacks you know the same problems the
books which are best in the series which
for the record first and only necropolis
Sabbath martyr traitor general and Blood
Pact blood pack might actually be my
favorite controversial the best books
are the ones which overcome those
difficulties and in particular have for
example good antagonists they have good
character development as a whole as a
series I'm not gonna recommend it to
absolutely everybody but if you would
like to read a small tree and you like
military sci-fi if you like a sci-fi
action then it's a hard recommend from
me the entire Gaunt's ghost series
however is picked by brothers of the
snake also by Dan Abnett which again I
have reviewed in a previous video
basically if you're interested in
Warhammer if you've heard me talk about
it this is probably the single best
individual book that you could read to
get into it and also it's a sapling not
a redwood so small the time investment
it's a gateway track be very careful
with your wallet then coming in at
number three The Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks by Rebecca Skloot this
book is great at all time you know
everybody seems to recommend it for
people that are interested in doing
medicine for example because it has a
lot to say about medical ethics
basically Henrietta Lacks was an
individual she was more than an
individual she was a black woman in the
south
of America who fortunately died at a
relatively young age but her cells were
kept in a lab and basically found to be
immortal so hence the title they kept
dividing and dividing and they are still
in existence all over the world they're
called hella cells Henrietta Lacks the
problem is that these cells were taken
and cultivated without her family's
knowledge and so her family had no idea
that her cells are being used all over
the world and medical research and the
book is basically an interesting
blending of storylines looking at the
science of her cells being used but also
the story of her family then story of
Henrietta herself because it's a rather
tragic story it's really quite sad but
also what's sad is the story of her
family finding out about these cells how
they're being used it's kind of got a
bit of everything it's it's a
beautifully written book it's it's
fascinating to read the science and the
human story you know I can scarcely
think of anybody that wouldn't find this
interesting it's one of my favorite
books that I've read in the past couple
of years you know number two and with a
lot of the same arguments for it the man
who mistook his wife for a hat by Oliver
Sacks another book which everybody seems
to recommend especially if you're doing
medicine I actually have a friend who is
specializing in psychology we went to
Oxford together he did medicine radio
physics and I asked him if he'd read
this and he was like yeah I wrote a
personal statement to apply for medicine
yes I read it for those of you that
don't know Oliver Sacks is a doctor a
late Oliver Sacks actually died not too
long ago basically looking at
neurological disorders that was his
specialty and this book is a kind of a
series of case studies looking at
individual patients who had different
disorders I don't think there's a single
repeated disorder in the book I might be
wrong the thing about it is that unlike
the hidden life of trees for example the
individual chapters are you get a good
amount of depth a good amount of
interest I think some of them are very
short but for the most part they're long
enough to be sort of fully formed short
stories almost you really connect with
these people and you connect with Oliver
Sacks you get a real sense of the author
in this that's partly because of the
experiences his experiences which was
put into the book but also how beautiful
his pro
is the way that he writes this book is
just beautiful it's it's basically
poetry it may well be the most
beautifully written piece of nonfiction
I think I've read a bit like Henrietta
Lacks
you've got the science angle to it
you've got the human angle there's also
a lot of comedy in this some sometimes
intentional sometimes unintentional you
know the half of the patient it's a
fantastic book so one of those books
which can potentially change your life I
haven't yeah in case you can't tell I'd
recommend it and then coming in at
number one for 2019 silk roads by Peter
Frank a patent I had to admit choosing
between these top three was very
difficult the silk road's I think edged
it because it had a similar effect to me
on me that sapiens by Yvonne L Harare
did is a broad sweeping look at history
and it kind of fundamentally changes the
way that you look at the world sapiens
changes the way that you look at power
structures the way the world is
organized the Silk Roads makes you
really look at a world map and it makes
you really look at how overstated the
role of certainly Western Europe is in
global history and how we are presented
with it really quite a skewed
representation of history well what's
interesting is that the book accelerates
so no I mean the opposite I mean
decelerates in that it covers a large
chunks of time per page at the beginning
and then gradually it gets more and more
zoomed in as we get close to the present
it dedicates more and more time to the
events because this book starts with the
very earliest civilizations the very
beginnings of agriculture in the Middle
East and the connections that were
starting to form between Africa and
Europe and China along the titular Silk
Roads that road that at one point
transported silks from China to the West
and it starts as I say the very earliest
of civilizations and it finishes post
9/11 it finishes right up to the present
day and in fact he has released new one
which is sat over there the new silk
road's which i'm going to be reading
this year and i got very high hopes for
and what by doing this it really puts
everything that you know about the
Middle East and
think about the history of consonants
relating to each other the history of
the Occident and the Orient you know
whether one was dominant over the other
or not in a completely different
perspective and also how effectively
it's the same relation over and over
again but the commodity might change at
one point it's not silk that's going
along the roads it's oil
another point in history its slaves and
other points it's fur you know it shows
how much has changed and how much has
not like sapiens I I found it to be a
really exhilarating reading you know
really traveling of my words try to
think of how much I like it like the
best non-fiction it basically made me
realize a new way of looking at the
world and it made me realize a new way
of writing nonfiction in that this is
written in a similar manner to a
textbook but in a way that is incredibly
accessible I think Peter franca Pound
has done something amazing with the text
of this in the same way that Oliver
Sacks did with the man who mistook his
wife for a hat it gives you a new
reference point you know in life we're
all prisoners of our previous reference
points you only think something is good
by comparing it to something that you
thought before was good this and Oliver
Sacks and Henrietta Lacks this year set
a new standard for nonfiction for me
which is I'm sure going to mean that I'm
disappointed by more books in future but
it has shown me how high the ceiling can
be I look forward to it being broken
this year but my word
these top three books in particular and
perhaps most of all the Silk Roads
they've really set the bar high so
excluding Gaunt's ghosts because I
physically can't hold all of the books
these were my kind of books of the year
in in order as I say if put links down
in the description to all of these if
you have read these and perhaps have a
different set of thoughts on them than I
have had then do let me know in the
comments and saying this if you have any
recommendations for what I should read
this year perhaps what your top book of
last year was pop that in the comments
as well because I'm always really
interested to hear the comments on these
books videos that just leaves me to say
thank you very much for watching I hope
you enjoyed you can get the video a like
and a share if you enjoyed it I guess
that's how YouTube works right and yeah
that's a bit basically just leaves me to
say I will see you in the next one
thanks for watching
[Music]